almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it as I've
already told you yesterday was the
biggest single day decline in the stock
market in terms of points in the history
of the United States the biggest
percentage decline in 12 years dating
all the way back to 2008 Donald Trump
had an absolute and total meltdown as it
was happening Donald Trump's actions are
showing that he is afraid of what's
going on with the stock market and the
virus he's not shaking hands with people
he thinks journalists on Air Force One
are gonna try to infect him weaponizing
the virus and check out his Twitter
meltdown as futures were crashing
yesterday as the stock market was
imploding yesterday first before the
stock market opened at 9:30 a.m. Eastern
Time futures were collapsing futures are
a leading indicator of what the stock
market is expected to do during the day
a Donald Trump tweeting starting very
early in the morning quote the
obama-biden administration is the most
corrupt administration in the history of
our country this is of course untrue
compared to Trump's administration alone
but it's unrelated to what we at the
time suspected was going to be the
biggest single-day stock market decline
in history and it was on a point by
point basis then still in the pre-market
hours we can tell the stock market's
about to dive and Trump starts tweeting
about MSNBC or as he calls it MSDN see
quoting saying Trump has out mastered
the deep state he's light years ahead of
us MSDN see I disagree says Trump we
have a long way to go there are still
some very bad sick people in our
government people who do not love our
capital C country in fact they hate our
country the country is collapsing around
him we have a completely out-of-control
medical situation that he is way in over
his head in terms of being able to
handle
he's arguing with what a TV network says
and calling people haters of the United
States then he goes into the Bernie
Sanders material tweeting quote now the
Democrats are trying to smear Bernie
with Russia Russia Russia they are
driving him crazy older Americans are in
grave danger and this is what he's doing
and this is what he's saying while
insisting everything is under control
everything's fine nothing to see here
then the stock market actually is
imploding throughout the day so quickly
in fact that it triggered some failsafe
methods to halt trading in the middle of
the day and Donald Trump tweets quote
cryin Chuck Schumer said you will pay
the price for this you won't know what
hit you referring to Chuck Schumer's
comments about Supreme Court justices
that is far beyond simple rhetoric that
is a physical threat or at least a
threat that you better vote for us
trouble ahead
we had like 5,000 or more new virus
cases yesterday stocks declined so much
so quickly that fail-safes are enacted
and Donald Trump tweets the fake news
media and their partner the Democrat
Party is doing everything within its
Semmy considerable power it used to be
greater to inflame the virus situation
far beyond what the facts would warrant
surge in general the risk is low to the
average American people are dying around
him he has now been around congressman
Matt Gaetz
who is in self quarantine after coming
into someone who was carrying the virus
at CPAC and Trump is late to the game
he's not doing enough he doesn't
understand it or he pretends not to
understand it and all he cares about is
media coverage of him it is truly sick
it's bad it's horribly embarrassing and
my real concern is that other countries
will start to get this under control
China already has I don't know exactly
what's happening in Italy we're hopeful
then in the next 7 days new cases will
decline drastically in Italy now that
they have gone into a absolutely
over-the-top full lockdown and
over-the-top I mean who would have
assumed this would ever happen three
months ago but it seems to be what they
have to do it's not over the top in that
sense it seems appropriately calibrated
to the nature of the of the outbreak
there I'm worried that it's just gonna
keep getting worse and worse in the
United States while it will improve
elsewhere and we will become the problem
we will be the ones not allowed to
travel to other countries we will be the
ones continuing to suffer the
consequences economic and health of this
because Donald Trump is so underprepared
and so in over his head again sick bad
horrible embarrassing I don't even think
that those terms fully cover it we are
continuing to cover this and other
stories from today's program on
Instagram make sure you were following
the david pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show and a little levity if
you're feeling down because of
everything that's going on and I
understand that I held a baby and a
picture of me holding a baby it's like a
loaf of bread or a football I'm holding
it it's on my Instagram page at David
Pakman follow me there a quick break
much more coming up